let's talk about our outrage of the week
because someone that none of us had ever
heard of until a week ago said something
and now we're all outraged about it
mince what a container we ought to go
crazy over every little thing
so Rachel Dolezal was the now former
head of the n-c-double-a chapter in
Spokane Washington had been living as a
black woman only problem she is not a
black woman although she's still saying
she's a black woman the only thing is a
little captured then she was born to two
white parents generally to be a black
person you have to be born to at least
one black parent that seems pretty much
how we've always thought of race right
now I get it she likes black culture she
identifies with black people she's done
a lot of good work on behalf of the
african-american community but that does
not make you black you don't choose your
race I know we live in a time when
everyone wants to be accepting of
everything and I as a liberal especially
I want to be accepting of people right I
want to hear people and especially when
people are trying to do something good
for to appropriate someone else's
culture so that you feel you can do good
for them in a weird way is the most
racist thing you can do so Rachel you're
not black you're a little misguided
you'll get over this little thing and
probably do more good work on behalf of
the african-american community but
doubling down as I saw today on MSNBC
saying I am black no you're not like
sorry